the jurogan experience
i mean you were successful pretty early
on in your life like how old were you
when you were in your first band
uh panic uh was the band before
metallica and and that was only for a
short period of time and i was 20 when i
was in metallica so i probably started
when i was around
maybe
17 18. but just think of that just that
statement i was 20 when i was in
metallica
i mean
yeah [ __ ] you all
that is crazy i was 20 when i was in
metallica that is a crazy statement
because if you just think about
the average 20 year old's life
and that
and that this is look at look at you
guys little babies yeah so cute
that's amazing does that freak out when
you look at that
no it doesn't um
it kind of brings me a little bit of
some sadness because of the way it went
down with you guys oh i don't care about
that um because cliff
oh yeah yeah
when you um left metallica
and then when did you go right into mega
death or did you other what did you do
right after metallica
i i think in my mind i went right into
the mega death but um
at the time i i was still kind of trying
to
you know
digest everything that took place well
you were still only 20. yeah yeah the
thing that bothered me the most was i
had all my music and i left it behind
and i said don't use my music and of
course they did
oh really yeah they used it on the first
record on the second record there's
parts of my music on a song on the third
record all the solos on the first record
are mine except that they're just
performed by kirk and
close but not the same
you know he's not a bad guitar player
did you get royalties for that uh well
uh most of them yeah but kirk got my
royalties for metal militia for many
many years and you know he has to see
the checks so i know somebody saw that i
wasn't getting paid
so there's a sadness and bitterness not
bitterness
i'm over a little upset you know it's
just money you know like you said you
know at the end of the day you know my
happiness and my family my wife and my
children are more important to me than
than anything in this world and um you
know i i i love our fans i i
have so many things in this life that
i'm happy about but
man it's it's
it's my family and and
obviously my relationship with god i i
take that very very personal and you
know i don't talk to people about it i i
don't i don't push it on them at all
it's my thing and and uh i just look at
it like where i'm at right now
um
yeah 20 in metallica and now look at me
i'm 60 and megahertz and and i'm a
grammy winner i'm a new york times
best-selling author all these things
that if if you know i was signing
autographs the other day joe and and i i
had these boxes there was 3 000 jackets
i had to sign
and for a moment i flashed back to
elementary school when i was in front of
the chalkboard i sort of got and i had
to write did you ever have to do that
yeah sure god and i don't know what
brought that up but i thought oh my god
i can't even believe that and and
thinking about you know where i'm at now
today and
and
just
how
the slightest deviation from where i was
going could have ended me up anywhere
else in the world